don't presume anything
and you can plan as much as you like
you often don't know
until you get there so there's been this
tension between
uh a natural
a natural instinct that i have to want
to plan and organize everything ahead of
time but i think what i have been able
to hone over time if i'm able to sort of
think
you know how how other people can sort
of take this is that while i've always
had a plan i've always been flexible
when that plan changes and i i think of
myself as someone who doesn't dig their
heels and well well this is what i'd
planned
i think it's good to have a compass it's
good to have a direction but be flexible
enough that if something changes
go with it um and i think that's that's
definitely helped me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another exciting 20-minute
leaders this is a really fun episode
made rachel kaplan business development
for fentec at team 8.
in 2019 she accidentally wrote a novel
and was just shortlisted for the 2022
vogel literary award one of australia's
most prestigious literature prizes she
also made alia to israel in 2015 from
her hometown perth in western australia
sits on the board of two non-profit
organizations and is a fellow in the
navajo network an exclusive program for
top talent or lim in the israeli tech
ecosystem
rachel kaplan welcome to 20 milliliters
thank you very much for joining me today
i know it's very very late where you are
right now so i really appreciate it and
thank you for being here
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
you know
different topics of conversation
throughout the show um
hearing your story i think will be
really interesting for a variety of
reasons you know the world that we're in
is so different from how i think
previous generations have experienced it
and talking about movement and the
connection between left brain right
brain creativity excellence sports uh
movement between countries i think it's
you know it's it's not usual that the
person can embody all these different
ideas into one coherent story and i feel
that that's what we're about to hear
here so thank you very much for
accepting the invitation to join the
show and for telling your story and i'm
really looking forward to getting to
know you better
wow thank you thank you very much for
having me
take it away rachel tell me a little bit
about you know yourself and how sort of
your your life journey played out
sure so my name is rachel kaplan i was
born and raised in perth in western
australia which is about as far away
from everything as you can possibly get
and i moved to israel i made aliyah
about six and a half years ago um and i
came to israel
fairly certain i'd never heard the words
innovation or high-tech before in my
life
everyone i knew in australia went on to
study medicine or law or accounting
and i came here and found myself not
only
overwhelmed and ready to build a new
life in a new country which is a whole
sort of topic on its own but i became
completely fascinated by the whole
startup and innovation scene here and
i managed to get my foot in the door
and i now lead business development for
fintech at team eight which is one of
israel's leading venture groups it's a
household name here
and i can say super exciting and dynamic
place to work with some of the best in
the business who are quite literally
roaming the halls of our office
in tel aviv um beyond that i am married
to eitan we have a two-year-old daughter
you can't see on the screen here but i'm
actually almost 35 weeks pregnant i
think
so really it's a very busy time
and on the side there are all sorts of
you know other things that have been
really interesting chapters and part of
i guess the journey to getting here um i
wrote a book um on the side which was a
bit of a happy accident
uh i represented israel in
netball which is kind of like basketball
um
particularly at an international level
in 2017
and i think in 2022 2021 is really where
i've come to terms with i guess what the
experience of being an immigrant really
has been for me um so there are lots of
different pieces that have brought me to
here and happy to
dive into whichever of the pieces you
think uh
could be interesting
so so i'm hearing you know the the most
interesting piece here obviously each of
these things on their own uh would be
worthy of an interesting conversation i
think that the you know the amazing
thing we have here is sort of this
combination of all of them so we're
talking about business development
within you know the fintech region that
team eight we're talking about sports
we're talking about author we're talking
about family we're talking about
immigration and culture all that tied
with innovation
is there is there some string that that
connects these in your life that
or sort of who is rachel as a person
because it because it sounds like you
know we're we're mixing a lot of left
and right brain we're mixing a lot of
different things that a person generally
does not necessarily experience in one
lifetime
well it's a really great question and i
think if you'd asked me a few months ago
i wouldn't be able to connect the dots
together um but it was actually in some
feedback that i received at team a quite
recently that really i had a bit of a
light bulb
moment which was that
um creativity really underscores a lot
of the
various chapters
of the life that i've had the journey
that i've sort of undertaken um and i
never thought of myself as a creative
person i suppose because i'm not
artistic or musical or any of the things
that you typically associate with being
creative
um
and i've come to redefine and understand
what creativity actually is and if i
look at each of the different things
that i've sort of the different tracks
that come together um there's
a sort of i guess
a capability to try and think a bit
creatively sometimes because there's not
much of a choice i can can give a couple
of examples and um
sport is really one of them again i grew
up in a country where sport was like the
religion of the country basically and
playing sport was just a part of
everyday life and the sport that i
naturally gravitated to towards the most
was
netball which as i said it's kind of
like basketball
it's mainly played in
commonwealth countries
and i played at a competitive level
growing up but i was never the tallest i
was never the fastest i was never the
strongest if i was to get the ball first
i had to be creative i had to think of
ways to get inside my opponent's head to
try and get there first i could never
rely on pure speed or pure sort of
genetic talent there had to be something
else about it and i only realized this
later on that in many other ways being
an immigrant is the same thing you know
you think of entrepreneurs and they are
basically starting with a blank page
they're starting
from scratch trying to build something
that
when nothing exists
um and immigrants are trying to do the
same thing immigrants are saying i've
got a very comfortable life
got all the things that are familiar to
me my family my friends my language my
culture the path ahead is both
predictable
and great and yet i'm gonna leave all of
that and i'm gonna start somewhere else
driven by something that is usually
irrational i can say
for myself the decision to leave
australia to come to israel is not an
easy decision but for me it was the most
natural thing in the world and when you
land on your feet you have no choice but
to be creative you can't leverage the
networks you have from the army when you
didn't do the army you can't leverage
the language and the ability to
communicate easily with everyone when
it's not your mother tongue there are so
many
moments in day-to-day life as an
immigrant and in the big moments as well
where you simply have to think out of
the box because there's not really much
of a choice
and with time i've come to see that
israel as a country is really the same
in that so much of the innovation here
to me is a product of the fact that the
geopolitical circumstances the fact that
there is there are no natural resources
what choice did israel have i guess but
to become creative and that's really
sort of i guess sprouted the seeds of
what we
see today um
it sounds like something like
you know you've positioned yourself
quite interestingly at a
sort of the underdog position time and
time again
right i mean it sounds like the
different things that you're doing all
you know the one common pattern that has
to do with all them is that you know you
when you started it you didn't have any
leverage over any other person that
would start the same position right
whether it's physically through netball
or whether it's you know through through
writing or through
um through business development in
fintech or even just transitioning to a
land of innovation and trying to figure
out okay how do i find myself within
this network
let alone creating a family
in a new environment sounds exhausting
right it sounds tiring but yet i think
some people just seem to be wired that
way for whatever reason you know could
have stayed the easy track in australia
when you enter that if you look at any
of the situations you were in what is it
that drives you
when you're the underdog when you
realize you don't have the leverage
um i think that by nature i'm someone
who
i think the pursuit of excellence is
something that was ingrained in me from
a young age and the irony of that is
that it really comes from inside if i
look at you know parents and school and
all the typical sources that you
naturally think that that must have sort
of been put on me
it really wasn't from a young age it was
very clear to me that nothing would
stand in my way i was capable of
whatever i wanted to do
um and there was nothing really that was
going to stop me and if i think of a
particular example i've actually i've
actually got a stutter so you would
think that doing podcast interviews
would be something that i would avoid
altogether
and i think back to high school when i
was on the debating team
it was almost duffco it was almost
specifically because of that challenge
that i felt the need or the desire to
really prove to myself that i could and
i think that when i look at the life
that you know i turned 30 in october
last year and i remember looking around
and saying if someone came to me and
said this is your life at age 30 i'd be
really really happy wow and i think that
building that
with all the challenges of immigration
and everything else
um i get a sense of satisfaction
that
um
really validates a lot of the decisions
that i've made along the way and so if
you're now looking at your next
challenge the nth challenge and i have
no doubt that
if we'll have a podcast in three years
time there will be two more crazy
activities that that you've undertaken
that were not you know conforming to the
traditional route
what what what
lessons do you take with you
towards your next adventure so as you're
starting something that you don't know
much about let's you you gain the
confidence to do it right what are some
really fundamental things that you take
with you that will help you succeed in
whatever you do
um it's actually interesting i've been
i've been grappling with this question
very recently i think i mentioned
earlier i wrote a book which was an
accident and that is something that
i never particularly set out to do and
that to me is the lesson in that the
story behind the book
basically was that my
my grandma who was one of the great
loves of my life she passed away four
years ago and
when i came back from australia having
been there for her passing and i came
back to israel i was overcome with this
sense of no one here knows her and i
need to almost recreate her and that's
where the writing helped every time the
grief hit i went to write
and what i wrote took on a life of its
own and really helped and evolved
through the grieving process and i had
zero intention to show it to anyone it
was very personal very much a
therapeutic exercise and it was my
husband who said why don't you show it
to a few friends i've got some you know
people that we share books and sort of
have
similar taste
and was the feedback from that that
really said you know maybe i've got
something here um
and just last week
i found out i was uh shortlisted for the
vogel award which in australia is sort
of this top book award for a manuscript
and
i look at that and i take the lesson
here which is that i'm someone who's
very organized and i like to plan i like
to think ahead but sometimes the most
magical things happen when you
just go with the flow and that's not
always easy for people who i think are
more type a the way that i am
um and i think that that is really the
message that i take into whatever comes
next because
thank god i'm extremely content with
what i have currently on my plates in
both my professional and my personal
life
and what i learn going forward is
sometimes you can't plan and maybe
that's going to be the most magical part
of it all
um
yeah that's really sort of how how i
think about the future a little bit
differently than i did even just a month
ago sounds like there's a lot of
dialogue between future and present and
and what does it mean to
to think through an opportunity and and
live through it and not necessarily plan
all the time
but but nevertheless you know we are we
are we are taught in this day and age
that you know planning is important and
you need to have sort of this trajectory
and where you want to get to and you
know whether it's in high tech or
whether it's in any other profession and
it sounds like this is something that
perhaps is less apparent with you but
maybe i'm wrong do you plan no you're
100 right and i can give and like it's
funny speaking to you certain examples
are coming up i got into
law school out of high school which was
sort of the prestigious place to go at
the top school in perth and i i remember
on day one sitting there in law school
thinking what am i doing here like that
was always you know if you were good at
the sciences you went down the medicine
track and if you were good at the maths
then you went down accounting and i was
more the humanities type so
law school was the obvious place and
that was just that had been the plan and
on day one i said what am i doing here
basically and i remember thinking how am
i going to tell my jewish parents that i
don't want to do law
and i called up
my mom and i said what do you think if i
don't do law and she said oh thank god i
don't know what you were thinking
so i think there's an element there of
don't presume anything
and you can plan as much as you like
you often don't know until you get there
so there's been this tension between
uh a natural
a natural instinct that i have to want
to plan and organize everything ahead of
time
but i think what i have been able to
hone over time if i'm able to sort of
think
you know how how other people can sort
of take this is that while i've always
had a plan i've always been flexible
when that plan changes and i i think of
myself as someone who doesn't dig their
heels involved well this is what i'd
planned
i think it's good to have a compass it's
good to have a direction but be flexible
enough that if something changes
go with it um and i think that's that's
definitely helped me i love it and i
think that's that may be the key
differentiator here because you know
probably every person has sort of a plan
right before they go to sleep they think
okay this is really what i want to do
this is where i want to get to and this
is sort of the plan sometimes we get so
fixed we're fixated on that i can
imagine that
that then we're not open to whatever is
happening in our day to day right we we
don't take opportunities or we avoid
trying out for these opportunities and
then we end up maybe make maybe making
our plan maybe not but
whether that was the best journey for us
that's probably debatable right i mean
it's uh and we'd never know and and i
think
what it also sounds to me is that you
you don't really you don't really have
regrets right i mean it sounds like your
your path is kind of one that optimizes
for a lack of regret in your own life
i think that's interesting because you
know i think it's jeff bezos who talks
about
the rocking chair test you know you're
80 or 90 years old in your rocking chair
and you're looking back at your life and
he talks about sort of regret
minimization as a strategy and i must
say i don't think about regrets nearly
as much as he does but i mean he and i
are in different places in life so maybe
his his approach is uh is okay as well
um i really genuinely believe that you
can't go back and change any decisions
that you make large or small and think
that you then know what would have
happened because there's this butterfly
effect of the chain reaction of the
small things that you change you can't
then map out what would have happened
differently it could end up com
completely off track from what you
wanted um and i think that you know
the experience of leaving you know i i
come from a very slow paced
very wide open spaces
very calm
opposite of israel place basically
and
you can never predict that you're gonna
actually feel more at home in the hustle
and bustle and the impatience and the
the crowdedness of a different place
compared to where you are and then
um that's where you find yourself that's
where you find yourself feeling the the
greatest sense of belonging um
and if that can happen
then
who knows what else can happen the other
things are really
small compared to that i think yeah
because that is so irrational and how
does your community deal with this
because it's not a
it's not it's i'm sure it's not easy and
it's not trivial to have somebody in a
close intimate life that
that doesn't that you know could could
change or could evolve and is open to
evolving and changing that obviously
impacts others so how how do how does
that cope into the personal life
what do you mean the the community that
i that i grew up in back in none of the
circle you know your close friend your
family here in israel i mean
and and speaking a little bit from
example right i mean you're i i feel it
being very open to these opportunities
and and changing and and shifting
passions and getting excited about
different things
it really it does impact the people
around me at least and and i have to be
conscious of how does my behavior and my
outlook on life and it's changing how is
this impacting sort of this relationship
that i've been building because now it
impacts them as well do you feel that it
has any impact on on your life
um
i think that one of the most profound
experiences i've had since moving here
has been joining a community that's part
of the
nevo
network this has really built a new
sense of community that i don't feel
that i had before and i can say that i
hadn't really given much time to think
about a lot of the experience that i've
had particularly as an as an immigrant
until this program
and it's through
connecting with this group of
like-minded or liam other other
immigrants working in high-tech
working their way to build this sort of
these many glass ceilings that we have
on top of us
it's really through that i've come to
understand how powerful it is to be
other around other really like-minded
people and understanding the you know
the the commonality that you can have
with people over a similar shared
experience even if someone's coming from
argentina or from mexico or from canada
or from wherever it is
um
you can really feel that
they're evolving with you the same way
that you are and when you talk about the
sort of the ripple effects of
you know the personal experience that
i've had on others i found it very
powerful and empowering
um to be able to connect with other
people who are doing that in their own
way but with the common thread of uh
that experience of having left things
behind coming here and and building and
people who
and this is really part of it that i
hadn't really come to terms with i
didn't realize that i basically felt
like i was born at age 24 because the
person that i was and for context as
well i moved to israel when i was 24 and
i was married within six months so i
literally had a new name and a new
identity and i knew everything within
six months of coming to a new country
and most people here don't know
what my name was even before they don't
know anything about the reputation or
the track record or the accomplishments
the the good the bad the ugly whatever
it was of what that australian person
was was just basically reborn from
scratch at age 24
um
and to speak to other people who are in
their own way are grappling with did
that life actually exist
or did i dream it did it belong to
someone else um
i think that when you connect with other
people like that you can think how can
we turn this experience into something
that is a an agent for good and an agent
for bringing people who think
differently and come from different
backgrounds uh into a place in a way
that is an asset in a way that is a
resource that contributes meaningfully
to the scene here
and that's really the challenge that's
been put to us not just how are we
personally enriched by these connections
and how we professionally enriched by
all these resources but what are we
going to add to the scene here what are
we going to add
to the country just by living our
everyday lives and building our careers
there's a way we can do that rachel
thank you so much this was so enjoyable
this is amazing uh i i thank you taking
a lot of insights with me from this
conversation and i appreciate your time
and um
enjoy the rest of the pregnancy and hope
that everybody's safe and healthy
and uh and and i just i'm excited to
continue following your journey and see
what other crazy things you do and
learning from your from your inner
motivation and i think that's awesome so
thank you very much